所有的亲戚都是客客气气的，
谁劝我，
我就说一下我现在的情况，
我身体有哪些问题，
精神有哪些问题，
我一个月吃药要花多少钱，
我现在欠多少账？
大姨我也想孝敬您，
看您经济方不方便，
方便的话你借我十万块钱，
哪个亲戚敢劝，
就问他借钱。
我今年是28，
我原生家庭是特别不好的，
我现在是在跑外卖，
一个月的话跑的话大概有1万左右吧，
不稳定。
我五六岁的时候父母就离异了，
我母亲怀我的时候，
她身体也不是很好，
还有肝炎，
生下我之后呢，
我身体也不是很好，
这几年呢，
也是有焦虑和抑郁，
我母亲离婚之后，
一直都是对我不闻不问的，
我父亲的话，
他有过三段婚姻，
她也是一个不是很负责任的人，
也特别虚伪，
他工资是还行，
一个月可能有个1万左右吧，
但是他的钱基本上可能就是车用掉了，
我从小就是我奶奶带大的，
二五年的时候我父亲他查出有艾滋了，
我想问你，
我这个外卖我感觉是不能一直跑，
想问问你这个工作上的意见，
还有第二个问题呢，
因为我在家里可能对我奶奶感情比较好，
但是这些年出了很多问题，
我不知道这个怎么去处理，
你从小长大的过程当中，
跟你爸爸有共同生活在一起的经历吗？
没有，
基本上就是。
过年回来，
因为他从小在我印象当中就像过年回来呀，
别人都是父母会带衣服鞋子之类的，
我感觉他从来没有过。
还有就是他查出有爱子之后，
伯母他们老是用孝道，
用感恩来跟我说要去面对怎么怎么样的，
因为我内心里面我是比较喜欢小孩的，
我是想结婚的，
但是后面就出现了这么多事，
然后我心里就慢慢淡化了这种想法，
也是有过几段感情，
但是很快就结束了，
我总结过这个原因，
可能是因为我不知道怎么去爱自己，
也不知道怎么去爱别人。
还有一个问题，
我想听听你给我生活上的意见，
你现在有女朋友吗？
没有，
今年是28岁，
现在自己有存款吗？
没有，
那你一个月你挣1万多块钱哦，
做外卖又比较忙哦，
那你平时钱花到哪里去了？
我现在一直在喝中药，
因为我心情特别不是很好，
喝中药一个月花多少钱？
2000左右吧，
其他钱花到哪里去了，
就跑外卖，
我是就跑了半年，
因为前面一直是在厂里面上班，
我们一件一件事情来说，
就你爸爸这个事儿，
如果你从小到大没有怎么跟他共同生活过，
又没有什么感情，
他这个人又不负责任，
对你又没有什么托举，
在你身上又没有进行什么投资，
也没见得给你买房，
没见给你买车，
没见得给你攒彩礼娶媳妇儿。
那我觉得大家。
就可以客客气气的相处，
什么叫客客气气的相处，
就是不相处。
不相处是什么意思呢？
就他问你要钱，
你确实没有，
客客气气的讲讲自己的真实情况，
不用打肿脸充胖子，
不用借钱，
不用贷款，
不用想办法说东拼西凑的去给他治病，
没有这个必要。
客客气气的相处，
不管是谁，
哪个亲戚说来劝你啊，
要对你爸感恩什么的，
都是客客气气的回答，
我只是没有这个能力而已，
我又不是说不感恩，
我又不是说没良心，
我又不是说不孝敬，
让你说去照顾她，
生病，
我自己吃饭都成问题，
我要去照顾他生病的话，
钱从哪里来？
谁劝我？
要感恩的话，
你能不能借我10万块钱？
哪个大姨劝你，
要去对你的父亲尽孝道的话，
姨，
你能不能借我10万块钱？
就用这一套，
对所有的亲戚都是客客气气的，
谁劝我，
我就说一下我现在的情况和身体有哪些问题，
精神有哪些问题，
我一个月吃药要花多少钱，
我现在欠多少？
唱大姨我也想孝敬您，
看您经济方不方便，
方便的话你借我10万块钱，
哪个亲戚敢劝，
就问他借钱好的，
这是一方面，
就是跟你爸的关系，
就是客客气气的不相处，
这是你爸的因果，
他该得的。
对于这种不负责任，
生了孩子也不管，
天天在外面东搞西搞搞女人的男的得艾滋病谁管你还想要儿子来管你啊？
哪有那么好的事情啊，
没有那么好的剧本给你，
这是跟你。
之间的关系，
其实我还有一个妹妹，
她比较偏心我妹妹，
我们从小关系我就跟她不怎么好了，
这几年吵的也是特别凶。
至于说奶奶，
我跟你说老人啊，
很容易满足的，
没事你给奶奶寄件衣服过去，
她高兴好久，
没事给奶奶寄个什么收音机，
寄个什么老人手机回去，
他高兴好久，
没事你给他寄点什么机量高，
寄点什么东西回去，
他高兴好久，
跟奶奶之间的关系就这么处。
再说到你自己爱自己这个事情啊，
其实我们东亚的绝大部分的年轻人，
不管是男人还是女人，
很少能从原生家庭里面学会爱自己这件事情，
很少从原生家庭里面得到真正的尊重，
平等的对待，
还有就是鼓励，
无条件的爱很少。
东亚家庭整个环境都这样，
所以大差不差，
我相信跟你跑外卖的这些小伙子当中，
有原生家庭比你更惨的，
原生家庭比你更复杂的，
原生家庭比你更难的，
没错吧，
对，
所以首先我们要打掉一个，
说什么事儿啊，
想想都是原生家庭造成的，
打掉这样一个思想基础，
既然我已经28岁了，
我认识字儿，
我还会用快递软件，
我还会用各种各样的手机，
那我在这个社会上生存肯定没问题，
就是你28岁的小伙子，
在这个社会上生存肯定没问题，
想饿死自己可太难了，
那怎么才能爱自己？
爱自己体现在哪些方面呢？
首先是对自己的身体负责任，
对自。
的身体负责任，
就如果我现在干的是外卖这个活的话，
那我出门的时候，
我开车的时候，
我过红绿灯的时候，
我超车的时候，
我一定是万分小心的对自己的安全负责任，
这是其一。
其二，
量力而行，
接单的时候我未必要干成，
说我们这边的销冠未必要干成，
我们这边的骑手的标王未必要干成，
那个在我身体允许的范围之内，
在我精力允许的范围之内，
我干到6000，
干到7000，
我觉得挺好了，
那就可以，
就是要休息，
要劳逸结合。
再有一个就是饮食，
你自己送外卖的，
你知道，
那就自己在家做点儿，
做点鸡蛋，
做点清汤面，
做点蔬菜，
炒点辣椒炒肉，
自己一日三餐，
自己的三顿要吃好，
要把它当成一个仪式感，
对自己好，
就是要对自己的胃好，
对自己的身体好，
完了之后你说你们快递或者干外卖不能干一辈子，
这事儿不能说光停留在口头上，
你要落到实处，
落到实处就是说我觉得我适合干什么，
如果我适合干修车，
那我就得花钱花时间，
我得学怎么修车，
如果我觉得我适合干一个什么别的洗车或者干嘛的，
那我就得去了解一下这个行业怎么才能入门，
我们不能说停在嘴上，
停在嘴上说我不能干送外卖送一辈子，
但是一旦闲下来了之后，
就刷抖音，
刷美女，
刷各种各样的直播搞笑不行，
你如果说心里想着我不是说能送。
卖送一辈子的话，
那趁着28岁，
趁着现在还没结婚，
趁着还没有孩子，
没有任何负担的时候，
我的一个月挣的8000块钱，
除了2000块钱用来吃药，
除了2000块钱用来吃饭，
剩下的4000块钱我就要砸到学习这件事情上，
我就要砸到学本事，
学技术，
哪怕我去学个剪头发，
我是不是都得接触几个剪头发的老师，
看看人家是不是真心想带我，
哪怕我想学做饭，
我是不是得了解一下，
就现在哪些菜系相对来说比较好找工作，
对这几年家里包括我自己也少很多事情，
我一心里在一直在动摇，
我这辈子要不要结婚，
反正一会儿想结婚，
一会儿又不想结婚，
想结婚的话，
我就感觉我从小就没有得到过什么温暖，
体会过家庭的温暖，
不想结婚的一方面就是因为我感觉我承担不了一个家庭的一些问题，
我觉得这个事情都为时尚早，
因为你现在才28岁，
你现在都没有真正蜕变成一个可以为自己负责任的人，
独立的人。
我刚刚都问你了，
有存款吗？
没有，
有什么其他的资产吗？
房子车子什么的没有，
现在说谈我要不要结婚的话为时尚早，
现在你需要一门心思做的就是养好我的身体，
养好我的心性，
给自己找一条出路，
本来就原生家庭，
没有人给你托举了，
那将来的话一切都得。
靠我自己了，
人是这样的，
一旦你养好自己的身体，
养好自己的心性，
给自己找了一条出路，
你积极，
你阳光，
你善良，
你上进，
在这个路上的话，
如果有人欣赏你，
有人不介意啊，
不介意你现在没房，
不介意你现在没车，
但是就觉得你这个人踏踏实实过日子，
又爱干净，
家里面啊，
做饭做菜什么的一把好手，
又很善良，
又愿意为别人着想，
有没有人愿意跟这样的年轻人过日子，
有的呀，
现在没必要说考虑我将来要不要结婚，
要不要，
这事儿都由不得咱们啊，
小伙子，
好吧，
那行好，
就这样啊。
我那天看到一个保安小哥哥啊，
他说他一年挣了10万块钱，
但实际上他的开销呢，
是花了12万还是13万，
因为他爸爸妈妈有生病啊什么的，
但那个保安小哥哥好像是在上海做保安，
他不光是做保安，
还做代驾，
还做自媒体，
长得胖胖的，
两个小眼睛非常可爱。
他每次发作品的时候，
他都说，
你们能相信吗？
我今天的饭是业主给我送的呀，
业主为什么给我送过饭呢？
因为那天有一个老奶奶就在这里走路走不动了，
提了很多东西扶着老奶奶，
我给老奶奶的东西拎上楼了，
老奶奶就觉得心疼我，
给我做了饭，
我很骄傲，
我真的看到那个小伙子啊，
那一瞬间呢，
我看到他的时候，
他善良。
他对别人好，
他有责任心，
他在自己的岗位上尽心敬业，
假设啊，
就这种情况下，
就跟这样的小伙子能不能过日子，
能啊，
有奔头啊，
如果说女方自己家庭条件也还可以，
自己又能挣钱的话，
前提条件是你先把自己活成那样，
就活成让别人相信跟你生活在一起，
你的善良，
有同理心，
能够体会别人的辛苦，
你把自己也照顾的很好，
遇到问题不逃避，
遇到问题解决问题，
生活习惯好，
不抽烟不喝酒，
因为本来你身体就不好，
你到时候再抽烟喝酒，
再糟蹋一下的话，
那身体更不好了，
干干净净的，
虽然说是送外卖的干，
每天回来洗完澡了，
干干净净的，
刮好胡子了，
家里面收拾一下，
有没有人愿意跟意过日子，
有的呀，
刚刚有个朋友说这段话，
治愈了你啊，
因为现在年轻人都不容易吗？
尤其是原生家庭不好才是常态，
我跟你们讲真心话，
原生家庭不好是常态，
原生家庭好是你的福气，
是你的运气，
是中了彩票，
记得点赞关注哦。